nothing's going to stop me
snow wind 40 below things like that
don't stop me
[Music]
couldn't be any better time to finish
this up
dogs are all resting well now it's time
to keep after
i don't want to leave this undone and
wait because this is just going to
accumulate
here rosie you play with your pig
and i'll take care of the window okay
jesse holmes has nearly completed the
new addition to his home in briscana
but with winter already descending on
the landscape and his new bedroom still
incomplete
jesse will need to work through the
bitter cold night if he's to be shielded
from the coming storm
all right one more step to make this a
room here get this window out and looks
like i can wiggle it out right here and
keep it from breaking
there's a big sense of vulnerability
moving this window i've been able to do
a lot the last couple weeks since my
surgery but i'm still really weak and
having to move this window is the crux
of this whole deal
there it goes there it goes
nice and easy
okay now it's time for the big lift
i i've been struggling for five weeks to
get strong again and i'm still 80
and this window is 100 job you know you
get one chance you drop it it breaks
i don't have another window to put in
here
oh man
i am having a hard time here
just ain't as strong as i was
there it goes
[Music]
all right
that's the final
screw locking it down here take a look
at it and
let it soak in i'm exhausted from a long
day at work but i'm glad that i
committed cut the window out got it in
there that's a big step now everything
is just making things aesthetic
rosie come
get your limelight come come
hey come check it out look we got a new
bedroom yeah look at all that new room
for you to terrorize in huh
yeah
huh do you like it
to me having this home here is a symbol
of never giving up
through these last couple years i've
been to the breaking point to where i
didn't think i could take it anymore and
then i keep going and block it out of my
mind keep focused
eventually you just become as hard as
the surroundings
it doesn't kill you and then it tempers
you and makes you stronger
i didn't just move out here to train
dogs i moved out here to become a better
man and every day this landscape molds
you into that
anywhere around here i feel a sense of
satisfaction this is a place with a lot
of future for me
it's
hard not to get emotional
this is something that i have wanted for
myself for so long
i don't even know what to do with it and
i'm just gonna let it play out from here
but i see
really good things happening in the
future
[Music]
you